My name is Chidinma.
I am Nigerian.
It's
[ Applause ]
I am also a frontend developer at New Lab.
I love to drink tea.
That's a fun fact about me.
Another fun fact about me is this is my first
time speaking at a conference.
[ Applause ]
So, please be kind to me, okay?
Okay.
So, I'm going to just go straight into my
talk.
I wanted to when I was preparing my slides,
I thought about how do I talk to people about
how we can all get along about the diversity,
about everything that happens in our community.
So, I decided, okay, let me look at what has
happened in the past.
Who remembers the Katie Bowman saga?
The woman who she was part of the team who
discovered the black hole.
Who remembers?
Okay.
Who remembers how much she was bullied on
Twitter, on Hacker News, yeah.
Who felt very angry?
You wanted to find those guys on Reddit.
Good.
We are all together.
Who has ever posted a question on StackOverflow?
Good.
I like the communication we're having.
Who remembers who was ever like posted a question
and then got very negative feedback.
Oh.
Yeah.
We're all in the same shoes.
My personal story is I posted my first time
ever I posted a question on StackOverflow.
And I think I it was about jQuery.
Something about jQuery, and somebody said,
can't you read?
And said go read the docs.
If you can read, go read the docs.
After refreshing for over three minutes to
get an answer, and somebody said, go read
the docs.
I'm coming from the docs, right?
If I'm coming from the docs and coming to
StackOverflow where everyone is to ask questions.
How do you want know feel as a beginner?
That was devastating to me.
I was trying to remember all the stories when
I was coming up with this talk.
Today we're going to have a conversation about
why this talk is important.
We're going to look at practical examples.
We are going to look at a proven solution.
We are going to explore ways to apply this
solution to our community.
We're also going to look another how working
on this problem can actually benefit us as
individuals and help our community.
Why do we need to have this conversation?
We need to have this conversation because
we are unique in so many ways.
We all come from didn't backgrounds.
We have different parents.
Even if we're sisters and brothers, I mean,
we have different ideologies, right?
We need to have this conversation because
can be despite our differences, instead of
embracing our differences, we are actually
making it allowing it to cause discomfort,
disconnect and friction within our community
and amongst ourselves.
Okay.
Practical examples.
I'm going talk about the condescending tone.
If you've ever asked a question on Reddit
and then somebody down voted your question,
right?
Or somebody said, this is not right for this
thread.
Is it called a thread or a room?
Right?
Somebody says this is not right on StackOverflow.
Have you ever been in code review with your
manager or team lead and somebody says, or
your team lead says what you did makes no
sense, right?
Maybe puts you down in a very bad way.
How did you feel?
Did you feel anger?
Did you feel sad?
If you felt anger, just like, okay.
Who felt sad about it?
Okay.
So, the reason I'm talking about the condescending
tone is I think we have a problem as engineers.
In our community, we have a problem with communicating.
I'm not sure everyone wakes up in the morning
and says, I want to be condescending.
I don't think people wake up and say, every
junior developer in my office has to hear
it from me today.
I think it's because we don't know how to
communicate.
And especially when we learn something new,
and the beauty of this when we learn something
new, oh, yeah, anyone who wants to talk to
me today, has to learn.
Let's say you learn about React hoops, for
example.
And tell yourself, anyone that asks this question.
This is not, this is what we're going to say
or to do.
A junior developer says something, no, that's
not how it's meant to be done.
We don't tell them why.
We just put them down.
That's not nice.
This is a problem in our community, and we
need to work on that.
Yeah.
Also, one that gets to me the most is the
backend versus frontend.
If you've ever heard about people say frontend
developers do not do a lot of work.
Frontend developers are just there.
I mean, you can relate to what I'm trying
to say here.
I have been in situations where people tell
me I'm a frontend developer so I'm not doing
as much work as the backend developers so
I shouldn't get paid as much.
Or I'm just there for decoration or something.
Maybe they didn't mean it that way.
Maybe I'm trying to be nice to them and they
didn't mean it that way, but this is a problem.
We are having so much division in our community
because we feel some people are doing all
the work and some people are doing absolutely
nothing.
Developers versus non developers.
I actually went around talking to people about
this.
I spoke to designers.
I spoke to people in the grid team, spoke
to sales and markets and logistics.
And people actually feel that we don't treat
them nice.
Shame on all of us.
We don't treat them nice.
We do not think that they play an important
role in the company.
And that is really bad.
We need to work on this.
Everyone in the company is working hard to
make the company profitable.
We shouldn't make them feel that we are smarter
than them.
We shouldn't make them feel that we are the
most hard working or we are doing the most
important job.
I mean, if we finish working on the product
and there is nobody to sell the product, there
are no sales people or marketing people, do
you think the world will see what we've done?
No.
Okay.
As a tech community, we must treat documentation
I saw this Tweet and I have to put it.
As a tech community we must tweet documentation
and infrastructure work with as much respect
as engineering.
We have to actually work on this.
Yeah.
I'll just give you a minute to read.
Read it quickly.
Okay.
This one we can all read to it.
And I was guilty of this a few months ago.
I used to be a React developer.
And I got hired to be a Vue JS developer.
But guess what?
I was always I always had the bias against
Vue JS developers.
I always said Vue was trash, right?
I mean, why would you use Vue when you can
use React?
Why would you use Vue when you can use Angular?
But I'm here to tell you today that this framework
shouldn't be so.
We shouldn't have these words.
They're all tools, right?
We are supposed to use these tools to actually
work on something, to create product.
The fact that we've had one bad experience
does not mean that we should spread our biases.
And if you ask me why I had a bias against
Vue, I don't know.
Maybe somebody told me Vue was trash and I
said, okay.
Everyone, Vue is trash.
And I did not even put and that is if question
actually set ourselves, why do we hate Angular?
Why do we hate Vue?
Why do we hate jQuery?
Sometimes we don't have a concrete answer.
Someone told us our or mentors talked on Twitter
and we said, okay.
If you're smarter than me and say Vue is trash,
then maybe Vue is trash, right?
I think this is a problem and we should it's
discouraging beginners from actually spreading
their wings.
Discouraging beginners from being with open
minded because we are just being biased.
How can we make this better?
Empathy.
I'm sure we've heard about empathy so many
times.
This is not new, and I will not waste our
time.
But empathy in the simplest forms is trying
to put yourself in other people's shoes.
It's trying to understand why people are acting
the way they are acting.
It's trying to when somebody flares up, trying
to understand why is this person doing this?
That's what empathy is.
Not just your colleagues, people in different
communities.
People from didn't demographics.
So, I'm sure if I ask everyone here, yeah,
we show empathy.
That's why I put the more in the brackets.
Because we all show empathy here.
So, how can we show more empathy towards one
another?
It starts with a question.
How would I feel if I was on the receiving
end?
So, let's say you're going through StackOverflow
and you see a question and you want to answer
the question.
Before you press send, why don't you ask yourself,
if I was a beginner or if I asked this question,
how would I feel if I got this answer I'm
about to send?
Right?
That's the question we should ask each other
before or ask ourselves, rather, before we
do anything.
Put yourself in the shoes of the person who
you're about to reply.
It may seem like a random answer, but would
you like it if you got that kind of answer
from people?
I'm sure it's no.
Why show empathy?
I'm sure we already know with seeing talks
about why you should know empathy.
But I would just use a few of them.
You should show empathy because you are going
to be treated better.
You're going to treat other people with care.
You should also show empathy because you understand
the needs of your colleagues and you also
understand the needs of your end users.
You should show empathy because when you show
empathy, actually understand what people say
when you're not speaking.
Understand my body language and I'm not comfortable
and this is not something I want to hear.
And you understand how to deal with conflict
better.
Also, I understand we did not start this problem.
I mean, I feel when we came into tech we were
answered in very rude ways.
But, I mean, we have the solution.
We can actually take a stand and say we do
not we shouldn't speak to other people this
way.
Right?
So, how do we how do we actually come together
to make this better?
I mean, imagine a community where there are
more mentors and very few bullies.
Maybe we should just tune into our inner minds,
right?
And try to imagine a community where there
are more mentors, less bullies.
Where you can ask questions on StackOverflow
or Reddit or anywhere and not get rude answers.
Imagine a community where everyone from every
demographic is welcome.
Imagine a community where there are no gatekeepers,
no one is trying to bring you down.
Imagine if we are focused on trying to bring
each other up and not trying to bring open
other down.
So, in closing I would encourage you to see
something, say something.
I would encourage you to pause.
I would encourage you to listen.
I would encourage you to change your point
of view.
I would also encourage you to apologize when
due.
I would also encourage you to speak up for
others.
Because it's not enough that we understand
how to empathize.
But when you see somebody actually bringing
other people down, say something about it.
I would encourage you to share what you know.
And trust me, our community will be better
for it.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]